[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen fußball israel
heute gibt's eine herbst orte zum
valentinstag und das besondere an dieser
torte ist auf fixe ohne besteck gestellt
habe das heißt ich habe keine herz
backform verwendet sondern hat ganz
einfache backform genutzt um diese
schöne herbst hatte herzustellen und
auch bei dekra führen braucht ihr keine
besonderen rechte also wirklich super
einfach und auch ohne kitsch maschinen
oder kriegen dass sie eine küchenwaage
hat er brauche ich meine küche wartet es
geht alles mit bechern und erpressen und
deswegen denke ich ist es richtig wir
sind rechtlich immer ganz toll oder gar
nichts das würde ich jeder zuschauen und
backofen in europa natürlich ist die
situation genau also ich hab dir so
dekoriert dabei könnte auch gerne an das
dekorieren und ich zeige euch jetzt
gleich einmal wie ich den schokokuchen
darunter hergestellt habe und sag ich
dafür mal ja nie weiß baugewerbe gut für
den bäcker kuchen braucht ihr auch keine
küchenwaage das machen wir alles mit
einem wecker dafür brauche ich jetzt
erstmal vier eier
sie kommen in meiner wünsche sich eine
fräse saal und etwas angepackt und wenn
er kein mann electric habt könnt ihr
auch vanille flug annehmen
schmeckt nicht ganz so gut in vanilla
extrakte steht auch wann diese kunst im
kart dann braucht ihr noch einen becher
schmand und diesen becher weil ich jetzt
aufheben dass meine maßeinheit die tut
haben versucht jetzt erst mal ganz kurz
in hand for gerät
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt ein bäcker zucker mit
rein
[Musik]
ein bäcker kakaopulver ein päckchen
backpulver 1 becher sonnenblumenöl und
eigentlich das problem dass
mineralwasser
die zutaten werden jetzt kurzfristig
alles verbunden hat
[Musik]
und den teig für dich jetzt in einer
vorbereiteten backformen wie könnt ihr
zum beispiel einfach im backofen und
springform ihr braucht einmal einen
eckigen klammern und einen roten backen
der hatte 20 zentimeter im durchmesser
und die eckige backform hat etwa 20
zentimeter seitenlänge aber wie gesagt
falls ihr diese backform nicht habt
einfach eine kleine springform nehmen
und eine kappten backform oder zum
beispiel ein backblech und später kann
es zurecht schneiden
[Musik]
paris abgibt fühlt sich es läuft hier
oben am rand immer ein bisschen was aus
das ist aber völlig normal habe die
komplette menge in den zwanzig
zentimeter backen gemacht wenn die
gleiche menge noch mal machen und in den
eckigen wagram erfüllen und je nachdem
wie hoch ihre torte haben möchte reicht
die menge für beide der fahne keyboard
orte um ihnen eine hohe herr pfarrer
haben möchtest dann müsste eben zweimal
den teig machen
der teig wird jetzt noch vor heißen
backofen bei 160 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 45 minuten gebacken
ich werde auf jeden fall mit dem
zahnstocher hat die stäbchen probe
machen und weiden abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
beide kuchen sind jetzt abgekühlt und
zubereiten wir jedoch super einfach
zeitlich mal geführt hatten
ich mache bei einer 50 gramm davon 400 m
schlagball 250 kva ein teelöffel
bernapark etwas von exakt eine
unbehandelte zitrone ist dass die fotos
zucker und lebensmittel verpasste im
roda erst einmal nämlich die mascarpone
und geht sie in eine rührschüssel und
bevor hier die sahne dazu kommt früher
schon mal schön geschmeidig
bei niedriger zu verlangsamen
[Musik]
und auch den puderzucker und da könnt
ihr selbst entscheiden wer es gerne
dafür möchte dann gibt er einfach diesen
märkten und weniger nachgefragt habe den
röhren
jetzt kommt der quark mit rein und auch
noch meine lag komplett ohne schalen
april
[Musik]
und an dieser stelle könnt ihr auch
deine lebensmittel fahrt nach zufügen
kann ich mich immer verpasste weil sie
einfach die konsistenz dieser masse
nicht verändert wie jetzt über die
flüssige farbe jetzt wird die creme
aufsteigt geburt aber achtet darauf dass
er nicht zu lange wird in der savanne
von ansonsten würde die dame gerinnen
und die queen wird fällig die cremes
kurzen kühlschrank und in der zeit kann
ich schon mal die kuchen bildungsbereich
zu schneiden
zum zweiten nämlich jetzt ein großes
messer oder einen kuchen messer und
setzt hier an gleich mal die oberfläche
weg damit der kuchen geben wird jetzt
kann ich mit einer hand den kuchen
training mit der anderen durch wetter
halte und entweder schneidet low durch
oder ihnen durch zum beispiel einen
faden
aber ich schneide ich immer ganz gerne
mit orten weg aber wenn man wenig habt
kann man auch einen facebook schaden
nehmen wenn hier ein und dann einmal
durchziehen
[Musik]
und den kreistag halbieren und nehmen
die zwei oberen teile schon mal weg
[Musik]
die teile noch zugestanden werden und
zwar muss ich jetzt noch mal genau
kontrollieren 1945 und werde ich hier
auf ein quadrat mit 19 5 cm seitenlänge
zu schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt zusammensetzen
ihr müsst einfach mal schauen welche
größe pop platte hat ihr könnt ihr den
kuchen immer noch etwas kleiner
schneiden und war werde ich ihnen mit
etwas marmeladen geben auch bestreiken
ihr könnt ihn zum beispiel auch mit
bisschen rum trinken oder auch in einen
anderen gewerbe nutzen
[Musik]
darüber kommt jetzt eine fliegt von der
schönen creme und damit die tortenplatte
zum verbleib nimmt vier und legte unter
dem rand bedford um handyporto dann
komplett mit der creme bestreichen
[Musik]
die rettung bequemen brauche ich jetzt
noch gleich für die dekoration kämpft
aber noch einen tipp für euch jetzt hier
etwas später kubatur in einen
gefrierbeutel und verschließe den krieg
und den hang ich jetzt in einen topf mit
heißem wasser ich meine dem radweg an
das wasser das ist aber nicht mehr
kochen kapiert aufgemacht und kann ich
die restliche training ohne deinen sport
ist aber weit weg einschlug beutel habt
und keine stelle hat zum beispiel könnt
ihr den rand zu lassen oder sie müsste
auch schokostreusel frankleben wie du
eine art schwarzwälder kirschtorte
[Musik]
mit dem stück beutel leckere jetzt den
rand der torte
[Musik]
hier eine kleine spitze beim jeffrey
buttle ab und kann die torte fertig
dekoriert habe ich noch ein paar zucker
herzen und wird häufig komplexen
obendrauf
[Musik]
nach dem motto probieren
mein dekoren könnte wirklich so wie ihr
möchtet da kann ich glaube ich nach
machen
ich probiere geschmack aber was schmeckt
eigentlich vorher sagen wie in ganz ganz
saftiger marmor
möglich also er fest
also ich ohne werkzeug wo jeder
nachmachen kann auch man nachmachen kann
zb und man kann auch im prinzip wenn man
hätte man damit leben nimmt die tat auch
nicht von damit überstehen aber ich find
more gar nicht weil ich für mein kampf
mit der creme richtig schön dekorieren
deutschen thema shopping zucker
reingemacht
dann freue ich mich wenn dieses set nach
macht und dann könnt ihr uns gerne ein
foto auf dem programm oder auf feldern
und uns verlinken und wir werden es uns
anschauen also schön weit über wochen
hier auch menschen
sich um armut
von den zuschauern eine arbeitskollegin
die lacht mich aus
danke effekt nur meine selbst gekauft
habe ich für die dekoration auf die
einkaufsliste geschrieben
wir haben mit globus auf kunden und alle
schon nur deswegen gibt es auch beim
hinflug videos gefunden die rosen
bekommen das schreibe ich dann vor
sachen und rote rosen und dann bereits
darüber geld also viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis zur nächsten wahl
investiert um ihre gesänge hat mir
geschrieben
dafür kommt nicht mehr raus
[Musik]